as of this moment the w-h-o and the
population council estimate that about
50% of us live in cities and the other
half of course live somewhere else the
other thing we can learn from NASA of
all places is how much land those 7
billion people half urban half rural
actually need to produce their food
every year and it turns out to be a
slice of South America so the size of
South America and landmass is used just
to grow our crops that we plant and
harvest I'm not talking about the
herbivores like the cows and goats and
the sheep so when you think about how
much food is consumed by cities let's
say half it takes half of the size of
South America just to produce it
now if the human population continues to
increase which we expect it will so over
the next 40 years you might have 3
billion more people to feed and you look
around for the land where that's going
to come from in terms of traditional
farms and you don't find it it isn't
there so the biggest problem facing us
as a global species is where will the
food for the next 3 billion people come
from so it could come from some place
other than a traditional farm and and
the question is could vertical farming
solve that problem so by vertical
farming and a vertical farm I mean any
building that grows food inside of it or
in which you grow food which is taller
than a single story so there are many
examples of vertical farms out there
which are not traditionally thought of
as towering gardens of Eden so to speak
as the images on Google might suggest
from some of the planners and designers
that have submitted their own visions of
what they think a vertical fund should
look like most of those would satisfy
the cover of any science fiction
magazine I could think of and and
attract a lot of attention and get
people to ask well what is that building
and what is it doing but
we're not pretty close to seeing those
yet I think those are going to be
expensive and they're going to take a
lot of rethinking with regards to urban
planning but we don't have to do that in
order to have vertical farms already
there's a vertical farm in Singapore
it's a brand new building it looks like
a greenhouse from the outside but it's
four storeys tall but it's a clever
design it it uses traditional growing
systems though it uses soil based potted
plants on a series of conveyor belts
which migrates the plants by gravity
some kind of a grandfather clock like
apparatus which actually moves this
conveyor belt of plants near the windows
maybe once or twice an hour so that
every plant gets the same amount of
sunlight during the day at least because
it rains every day there's certainly no
shortage of water for these plants
either and uses traditional fertilizer
and the guy has moved from a 2,000
square foot operation to a 20,000 square
foot operation the same there's a
vertical farm that's been on the drawing
board for a long time now I'd say five
years which is in the final planning
stages and about to dig a hole to make
room for the foundation in Sweden it's
called plant agon and the plant agon
corporation is a combination of private
investors and the Onondaga
indians of northern new york state hence
the name plant a gone
and it's a very altruistic group of
people they want to show the world how
to farm in another way so that indeed
these two a three hundred and forty
thousand square miles of hardwood forest
can start to be given back to nature and
to perform the job that they were
originally selected for and so I think
they should have their farm it's about a
14 story building that they're planning
it's a mixed-use building because it's
got offices on one side and a growing
system across the entire facade of the
building on the other side of the
building so imagine yourself sitting at
a conference or some sort at 10:30 in
the morning it's bad time to go out and
pick lunch
so everybody gets up from the table when
the meeting is over they have their
trays and their little bowls and they go
and they go up and down an elevator and
they select tomatoes and cucumbers and
zucchinis and all kinds of green
vegetables and they come back and sit at
the commissary and have lunch
sounds like a fanciful science fiction
like scene but you can already do that
at persona Oh - in Tokyo persona Oh - is
a very interesting building it was built
in 2010 it is nine stories tall and each
floor has a different set of edible
plants growing in it it's not a building
dedicated just to growing food in fact
the people inside our human resource
oriented they help companies design
retirement plans and benefit plans for
hiring and stuff like that but indeed
when they want to go to lunch they don't
have to leave the building
in fact they can even go down to the
first floor and pick rice and bring it
upstairs winnow it the grains are then
given to the chef the chef then boils it
up and makes them a rice dish with the
vegetables that they've already picked
um for that kind of operation it can't
get better than that
meaning I'm not at all privy to the
energetics of how much energy it costs
for that building to operate but I do
know that the employees are extremely
happy so vertical farming I think
arising from an idea in 1999 in a
classroom that I taught to see where
it's come in the last let's say twelve
or fourteen years has been remarkable I
would say everyone